It's hardcore history,
I've always said some of the best things
we do around here,
our apologies,
and so I want to apologize if it seems
as though our subject matter and um,
and the stuff we're talking about lately
all kind of falls into a narrow sort of
subject matter or a historical period.
It's mostly been 20th century stuff.
It's not by design,
but I don't work by design.
I work on inspiration and sometimes
opportunity for example,
the opportunity to get a guest like the
one we have today.
So things don't always work out in a
balanced sort of way.
What'll probably happen is that we'll
end up flipping at a certain point and
then I'll start getting emails from
people saying,
why do you never talk about 20th century
stuff?
So we're just probably balancing things
out in the other direction.
I'm going to talk to her.
Max Hastings today.
Those of you who like military history,
uh,
have certainly read his work.
He's fantastic.
You wrote inferno,
he wrote a lot of other books.
If you look at his resume as it exists
now,
well if you had shown that to me when I
was 21 years old,
I would have said,
oh,
that's the guy I want to be
his resumes long as heck.
I mean foreign correspondent for the BBC
editor in Chief of the Daily Telegraph,
editor of the evening standard,
a war correspondent.
I'm author,
prolific author,
all around,
interesting person and he's written a
new book on Vietnam and 800 pages.
By the way,
I mean,
it's a tome at the same time,
you know,
if your library is like mine and you
like having certain subjects covered,
uh,
this is a necessary thing on my Vietnam
section for any number of reasons.
Hastings has a connection to the war.
He was a war correspondent in it and it
was sort of where he made his bones as a
young guy.
Go Google him and look at the images of
him when he was there.
And my wife thought he looked like a
beetle war correspondents are an
interesting species.
They don't make them like they used to,
I should say,
but at the same time there are still
some good ones.
They sort of have a foot in both worlds.
The soldier world and the civilian world
here of people that maybe don't know war
at all,
and so somehow you need to be able to
translate things into a language where
you can,
you know,
reliably convey information so that they
can understand it.
There's no way to reliably transmit
information on what it's like to see a
disemboweled village chief who's had his
stomach cut out in front of the
villagers by the Viet Cong as a lesson
not to cooperate with the Americans or
the South Vietnamese.
How do you,
how do you even relate that in a way
that people can understand and in a way
where they just don't not read about it.
At a certain point,
if you get graphic enough,
people won't read about it,
but then you haven't done.
You're supposed to do as a war
correspondent now.
Just so you know,
it's only personal weakness.
That probably kept me from doing
something like that.
I started reading because I was enamored
with it.
I'm all this stuff written and sometimes
written about their own lives that these
war correspondents had put into print
and at a certain point you start to
realize,
wait a minute,
do you really want to live with the
memories these guys have?
And they're sort of warning you
sometimes when you read their books.
I mean they're telling you what they're
dreaming about at night.
You deliberately over and over and over
again go to places where awful,
awful things have happened.
Things soldiers see,
by the way,
although they don't often want to be
there when it happens,
the war correspondent,
you know,
to them that's like the story,
right?
Let's go to the bad place.
Now.
Most of the soldiers are of the opinion
that they don't want to go to the bad
place.
They don't want to be there.
So Max Hastings did this job,
which always for me,
makes an interesting read because he's
filtering in real personal experiences,
tastes,
smells,
the lifestyle,
the culture at the time that you just
can't get researching secondhand
sources.
It would have been a very different book
of Dan Carlin had written it from other
people's stuff than to have a guy who
was there who participated in the
activities,
who interacted with all the people and
then has had decades and decades to see
how history played out since and to
think about it and to sort of integrate
it into his overall worldview.
The result is this new book and it's
worth picking up if you have interest or
you know a lot of you,
I know the Vietnam section on your
shelf.
If you wanted to say what the focus of
the book is,
I think it's rightly put where it should
be.
Although it covers everything.
That's the hardcore history books.
I mean,
you know,
the godlike view,
the hindsight view,
the leadership view,
the mid level view,
the hamlet view,
the,
the what it's like to be the guy on the
ground view,
which is why you get 800 pages or 26.
Our hardcore history series in the first
world war.
Either way it's like it's explainable,
you know,
understandable.
The most interesting part to me since I
already know the battle stuff,
although if you're into the battle
stuff,
he's awesome.
Historically,
Um,
the most interesting thing for me though
is to see how he can synthesize all this
stuff that's happened in the decades
since that era.
I was born in 1965,
1960.
I was born by the way on,
on the one of the worst battles of the
war,
the one that made the movie about,
that's my birthday.
November 14th,
nine 65 battle of the I valley.
Um,
but when I was a kid just starting to
become aware,
you know,
the older brothers and those people who
were the ones being drafted who were
living through all this stuff.
So in the 19 seventies it was,
it's hard to explain.
This was a transition period in US
history.
So this is what I want this introduction
to Max Hastings,
Sir Max Hastings interview to be.
Let me sort of cover the bases again for
those who weren't there and try to set
up a little of this and,
and,
and let you know why it's important to
you.
And why it matters in history,
in this case,
there is a before and after in us
history and we all know there are
several,
right?
You've got before,
after the civil war is a classic one for
people to use before and after the
Vietnam era,
go look at a photograph of Americans
will just choose a big city because
there was a lot of continuity in some of
the less big cities where people look
the same over the decades,
right?
They,
they are more conservative,
change,
less slowly,
less flashy,
more down to earth people.
But you get some photos from an la,
Chicago,
Miami,
New York,
some of the hip places supposedly.
And you show a photo from 1963 and you
compare those same people in a photo in
1973.
And you don't even have to say another
word.
You know,
that the culture has totally changed.
The Vietnam War is one of the major
factor points that account for this.
And there's several and they're much
talked about it.
A birth control pill.
The sexual revolution,
uh,
music,
I mean just there,
there's a number of major factors,
but without the Vietnam war you might
not have any of those things.
It's one of the prime movers and as a
friend of mine who was at the protest
back in the day pointed out and the
prime mover was the fact that many
people might have to go and suffer in a
war that they really didn't want to be a
part of that tends to concentrate the
mind in a way that just some ideological
cause wouldn't that prime mover pushed
forward a lot of the era's change in the
Zeit geist for lack of a better phrase.
I know that's kind of strange change in
the guys,
but I mean the rape culture flipped now,
once again,
not in some places the American
heartland was remarkably consistent,
but in many places and in terms of what
Madison Avenue is feeding you and we're
Hollywood's feeding you and all that
stuff,
the culture really changed.
Vietnam is an important point in that it
was also an era of extreme disillusion
with the government.
It's hard to explain once again how
different Americans were before Vietnam
and after if I just said,
we believed our government,
that right there is hard to square.
It's so far beyond what most people
today are raised with and it wasn't just
you believed the person in your party in
general,
Democrats and Republicans believed the
president.
It didn't matter who the president was,
you didn't think your government lied to
you.
Now that's naive of course,
but maybe if you look at us history as
equivalent to a person growing up,
maybe you're still in your dumb teens in
that era as a country and learning some
of these hard lessons like you know in
power politics,
people lie.
The problem is though,
is that you ended up with something
called a credibility gap where the
president had lied so many times that
the American people weren't buying it at
all.
Maybe if you had returned to some level
of perceived because it was always
happening,
some perceived normalcy with the next
president of Americans could have had
their faith in the honesty of government
restored.
But then you had Richard Nixon after
Lyndon Johnson.
So,
I mean,
that's like being hit with a left and a
right.
Lyndon Johnson would probably,
you know,
hooky and an upper cut,
you and Richard Nixon would hit you
below the belt,
whatever.
But as a country,
the seventies was about sort of
reevaluating a lot of the things
Americans had taken for granted in terms
of our self image and whatnot.
It's hard to describe how lone ranger
ish we felt at the time period,
how,
you know Philip Caputo in,
um,
well he,
he,
he was the veteran who wrote rumor of
war,
but he's quoted in supermax hastings new
book too.
Um,
let me read it to you.
He sort of describes the way Americans
felt about themselves.
Or remember this is in the Post Second
World War era where the US is just in
our own minds.
We saved Europe twice.
Then we rebuilt it with our own tax
dollars.
Then we protected it from the Soviet
Union and Communism and the Cold War.
I mean,
we were.
The good guys have history.
Hastings writes about Phil Kaputo quote,
Lieutenant Kaputo like General
Westmoreland saw himself fulfilling the
vision of John f Kennedy Kaputo then
says,
quote,
if he was the king of camelot than we
were his knights and Vietnam,
our crusade,
there was nothing we could not do
because we were Americans and for the
same reason,
whatever we did was right and quote,
their communist photos were quote the
new barbarians who menace the far flung
interests of the new Rome and to quote,
but it's hard to describe how the United
States saw itself as and the people,
especially in the marketing materials as
this force of good around the world and
with this dominance during the second
world war gave the United States a
dominance that lasted for 15,
20 years in terms of of a headstart over
a broken world and the power that that
gave you made you feel almost a
responsibility to do something good with
it.
In his book,
Sir Max Hastings writes,
quote,
there was in the US and enormous self
confidence and pride,
not unlike that of the Germans before
19,
14,
a consciousness of national greatness
seeking an outlet,
a searching for an appropriate challenge
to their powers and refusal to believe
that any problem was beyond their
capacity to solve statesmen who might
themselves have doubts were conscious of
a great ground swell of public opinion
bearing them on and quote.
This was the era where John F Kennedy
was saying,
you know,
we will bear any burden for the success
of liberty,
the sacrificing that the country was
willing to make.
It was the era where young people were
motivated by a sense of idealism that in
some cases lead people to go to other
countries and build,
you know,
farms and chicken coops and his work in
the Peace Corps to others who saw a
similar sort of mission to help people,
especially poor people in undeveloped
countries who needed it.
By giving them a government that was
free.
So you see this idealism amongst all of
these people across a wide spectrum of
types.
Now,
as far as background in the war,
so we have some context here.
I didn't go into this with a Somax Max
because you know,
let's not deal with the stuff we can all
find out beforehand,
but the Vietnam war,
as many of you know,
is something that grows out of
colonialism.
It was one of those territories that a
colonial power from Europe,
in this case,
the French,
a controlled.
It was French Indochina.
They treated it the way that colonial
powers usually treat these places.
Puppets,
they were bringing civilization was the
line,
but truthfully,
I mean it was a bunch of French people
in Nice hotels with Vietnamese waiters
and whatnot.
That doesn't mean that there weren't
people that liked it in Vietnam,
but when the Second World War was over
and you know,
the anti colonialism wave was unleashed
across the world.
Vietnam fell into a pattern of a lot of
other places that we're trying to throw
off the yoke of their colonial masters.
And in the case of Vietnam,
there was a war before the American
version of the Vietnam War for a long
time.
A very bloody nasty,
dirty war between the French and what
were called the Viet Minh.
It was sometime during this period where
the ideas of fighting for Vietnam
nationalism,
you know,
the,
the nation state a free Vietnam for
Vietnamese run by Vietnamese.
Um,
at some point there are communists who
become part of that movement are always
part of it.
And so there's this connection between
these,
these militant nationalist Vietnamese
movements and communism.
And this will be a poison pill for
countries like the United States
throughout the later
part of this conflict because when the
Vietnamese eventually,
after some nasty,
nasty battles are able to win their
independence from the French,
the United States has already gotten
their toe in the water in that region.
Not because they really want the French
to be the colonial masters anymore.
But because of that worry over
communism.
And that's another thing that's hard to
describe to people today is the role
that the fear of communism played in all
the decision making and all the
calculations.
Vietnam was just one of the many
countries that was supposedly part of
the domino effect where you might say to
yourself,
as many Americans did,
they didn't know what Vietnam was.
They couldn't pronounce it,
they couldn't find it on a map,
so why do we have to send our boys on
our money to go fight and die there?
Well,
here's what happens,
and remember,
this isn't Malarkey.
The people who are spouting it generally
believe it,
but this is just another country that
will be toppled by the communists and
then that country will be consolidated
and start to try to topple the person
next door.
The French had a different analogy.
They didn't use dominoes.
They they,
they use bowling pins,
but the idea and the image is the same,
right?
It's A.
It's a toppling from one another to
another and eventually you'll have the
Soviet Union.
In Mexico there were a lot of problems.
It turns out in hastings is book as good
at pointing this out.
There were a lot of problems in the
decision makers understanding of all
this,
which in hindsight seems crazy because
when you look at how many people would
die and all these wars and how many
would be killed.
Hastings book focuses on the civilians
more than anything and,
and rightly so,
I think,
um,
but when you see all of that,
you yearn for a reason and you yearn for
just wanting to believe that the people
who are making the decisions are at
least well informed that they've gotten
the experts,
that they,
they've got people explaining to them,
well,
let me explain the difference between
Soviet communism in Chinese communism
and the relationship of,
of Vietnam to either of those,
I mean that,
that was already in some cases below
where the threshold where anybody was
paying attention and for much of this
conflict and for others during this time
period,
there's this belief that Moscow controls
everything in the communist world and
that just wasn't true.
But if that's something you're basing
all your decision making on,
well it's no wonder that things worked
out the way they did.
Sometimes.
I mean,
there were occasions where our
government just thought the other side
was being stubborn when in reality we
were talking to the people who had no
control over the events we wanted to
influence and we didn't even know it.
It's hard to believe you could have such
momentous decisions regularly made with
such either bad intelligence or lack of
understanding,
but let's be honest,
this is one of the things that waiting a
couple of decades or in this case five
decades after the events so that makes
clear you have a chance and another
thing,
hastings,
because very good at you have a chance
to get the other side's point of view to
interview those people.
I'm considering that we're starting to
lose that generation.
Just like the Second World War
generation hastings is booked,
might turn out to be one of those really
important things on a shelf for a very
long time because you can't replicate
those discussions he had with the
principals.
Nevertheless,
if you remember this period,
you remember that part of the problem,
you know,
in terms of our good guy image to
ourselves was some of the news that was
coming out of this place and what ended
up happening in a nutshell is something
that you see happen in a lot of other
places.
You saw it with the French in their war
in North Africa,
right?
In places like Algeria in the 19 fifties
where it becomes a dirty war when you
have civilians carrying bombs and kids
throwing grenades into restaurants and
people hiding.
I mean,
it's difficult after a while to keep
your troops from doing the sorts of
things that the folks back home imagine
that their troops don't do.
In the case of the United States,
things happen in the Vietnam War.
That if you had gone back a mere 15,
16,
17 years before and asked the American
public whether anything like this was
ever possible from American soldiers,
they would have denied to high heaven
the Mee Lai massacre,
for example.
But there was regular bad stuff going
on.
I mean,
if you're going to proclaim something
like a free fire zone,
which of course in Vietnam was famous,
which means that anyone you see in this
area is considered a bad person by
default.
Well,
it's not going to be a good tally at the
end of the year when you start trying to
figure out how many actual enemy you
killed versus how many people who just
got in the way wrong place at the wrong
time and that became another problem
with the war.
The war had very many.
There were constraints on the war and
the constraints are things that we still
talk about today because it was the cold
war and because people had nuclear
weapons and because the Soviet Union and
the Chinese were on the other side and
because we had just fought a sort of an
undeclared will,
really undeclared war that started
against Korea,
but ended up being American troops and
Chinese troops killing each other.
The last thing that anybody wanted was
another one of those,
so there was always an attempt to keep
the war confined to certain parameters.
Imagine you've got this fire burning and
you just want to make sure that the fire
doesn't spread,
but at all times any conflict,
especially one going on as long as the
Vietnam war did is a potential flash
point in world war three and let's
remember as bad as Vietnam was,
imagine how bad something like that
could have been if it became the
equivalent of,
you know,
Gavrilo Princip shooting an archduke in
Sarajevo in 1914.
We wouldn't be talking about two or 3
million Vietnamese civilians dying in
this war.
We would be talking about 100,
200 million people and us still clearing
out the ashes today.
So let's try to remember the,
the,
the big picture that the leaders in this
story are trying to juggle it all times.
So you have lack of good information
with nuclear weapons as your punishment
if you screw up.
No pressure there.
Right.
But the 19 seventies were about coming
to some sort of emotional terms with
this and then there's those of us who
lived through it,
it's almost not worth talking about
because we remember it so well and it
was so.
I mean,
it was beaten to death by the end,
let's be honest,
but new generations coming up,
don't remember any of this.
It was a very different postwar world
for the veterans who came back from
Vietnam because this was a war we lost
and Americans.
I can again say from experience,
we used to be very proud of the fact
that you could say we never lost a war.
You Canadians do not need to write me
about the war of 18,
12.
I realized that that's a eye of the
beholder issue a little bit and I don't
want to get into a couple of others with
you,
but you know,
you know what I mean?
Theoretically,
kind of sort of,
you know,
in our own minds,
we never lost a war.
Vietnam was hard to deny.
Vietnam also broke the army for a while
and this is a a point that's well
understood.
If you read about this kind of stuff
that's not talked about a lot,
what it did to the US army between let's
just say 65 and 70 was amazing.
Again,
something you wouldn't have thought
could happen to an American army,
but then it hadn't been put in that kind
of situation before.
As we said,
look at the French.
In Algeria,
you find yourselves in these kinds of
situations and all of a sudden it's a
little bit different.
You had drug abuse,
you add the short tour of duty.
There were a lot of things.
The army really looked at a lot of
things after the war to try to figure
out what had happened and if you're
interested in that subject.
By the way,
Andrew j Bacevich has written several
books.
I'm describing the rebuilding of the US
military after Vietnam and what was
required and the safeguards that the
military brass tried to put into place
to keep the civilians from ever putting
them in.
That situation again,
didn't work,
but there were safeguards put into A.
Colin Powell is written about this too
and he was involved in some of this
stuff,
but people don't talk about that very
much for the.
You know,
you could look at the American army in
1973 who and that's from the Vietnam War
and it wasn't just,
you know,
the,
the morale and whatnot.
I mean,
there was um,
a real,
I mean fragging was something that was
talked about a lot and you know what
fragging is,
right?
The shooting of your own officers or
the,
you know,
you throw a grenade at them when no
one's looking.
We were fragging our officers sometimes
you don't find a lot of that from the
Second World War,
but in the Second World War we had a
very different kind of us image.
And the thing about the images,
you kind of live up to that where you
try to write.
So you just stayed away.
Americans don't do this.
It became hard to say Americans don't do
this.
After Vietnam.
It was,
it was the war that proved that we were
human,
right?
We were,
we,
we were as good guys as we tried to be,
but we were human.
Anybody who goes back and dives deep
into things like the Filipino
insurrection or,
you know,
some of the native American war,
certainly,
uh,
we've proven this point before in us
history.
Nonetheless.
You kind of need to relearn it every
generation or two.
It seems
one of the other things hastings focuses
on and I think it's,
it's an excellent point is how bad the
other side was there.
His,
as he said,
a little self flagellation on the part
of Americans.
But he was a hard thing for us to
absorb.
I mean,
it's a huge deal.
Uh,
the country was,
was wrestling with huge issues in the 19
seventies to early 19 eighties about
this.
I was,
um,
I was in,
uh,
one of the early courses and 60 minutes
did a whole big thing on this because it
was groundbreaking at the time that
undergraduates were taking it at
universities where the Vietnam War was
on the curriculum.
And one of the things that they would do
is bring in these veterans to talk to
you,
you know,
in every class.
So I took one of the University of
Colorado and we had a veteran who sat in
the back of the class and we didn't know
he was a veteran because these guys were
like 32 or 33 years old when they were
talking to her class and sat in the
back,
the classroom the whole time and then
like after eight weeks or something,
stood up and said,
I've been watching this whole class as
part of my recovery.
I'm trying to come to grips with all
this.
We actually showed a movie in the class
that showed a helicopter door gunner and
he said,
that movie showed me.
I was the helicopter door gunner you saw
in that film,
boom.
But we,
we're all wrestling with things back
back then and it's hard to describe to a
generation now who grows up in an era
where no one ever believes their
government.
And that's just the right way to be by
the way.
And the United States is fully seen as
a,
basically a good guy,
but fully fallible.
I'm fallible.
Part was not something that people
thought of say in the early 19 sixties.
We were a force for good only in our
minds and so it was this huge mental
rearrangement in the seventies.
If you look at the material,
I mean there was a lot of introspection
and it wasn't just introspection amongst
the general population,
but the military also and the political
class when we eventually,
I believe,
was it Panama,
like 1989 or something.
When that happened,
I think President Bush,
the first had said something like,
you know,
we finally kicked the Vietnam Syndrome
or whatnot,
and the Vietnam Syndrome was the,
the after effect where all of a sudden
the United States didn't want to go and
mess with other countries for awhile.
We'd had enough of that for a while.
It wasn't just,
um,
the,
the soldiers who had died and were
willing to do,
or the veterans who were increasingly
showing signs of being a badly effected
by what happened to them in the war.
But the cost and the blow back and there
was just this feeling for a while,
no more.
But again,
time passes and people change and you
forget just how bad it can be when
things go wrong.
And make no mistake about it,
things went wrong in Vietnam.
The idea that the United States of
America after the Second World War were
still at this pinnacle of of industrial
might and military power.
The idea that a bunch of backward
gorillas in what we called a third world
country with no money and no,
I mean they've got no.
There's,
there's nothing that they could beat us
that right there was a hard pill to
swallow,
but it reminded military and political
leaders once again,
that war is not disconnected from
politics as Clausewitz so famously said,
and what you're really after in any of
these situations is a political
settlement or a political change.
If your enemy or your adversary or your
opponent does not give in when you beat
the hell out of them and give you what
you want politically,
you don't.
When the United States did not lose a
major encounter in the Vietnam war,
and the bigger the encounter,
the more likely the United States one
and one big,
one of the most famous.
Most Americans that know anything about
this war.
I have heard the words Tet offensive
before it was a famous Vietnamese
northern Vietnamese attack in many
places at once.
That was a disaster for them,
but it was not portrayed that way at the
time.
I remember one veteran explaining to me
just how unbelievable the casualties
were that the north Vietnamese and Viet
Cong suffered in that offensive,
but it wasn't about body counts.
They weren't fighting a war for body
counts.
They were fighting a war for a political
settlement and because the United States
had lied to it's people so often about
how the war was going,
what the other side did by sacrificing a
ton of their people and material was
say,
Hey,
war's not over.
And at the same time,
basically demonstrate to everyone that
what they'd been told was false,
which turned the people once more
against the political regime.
If you're in,
if you're,
if you think about this,
I hate to do this because it's,
it's,
um,
there's no respect.
I mean,
it just,
it seems wrong.
But if you think about it like a game
and you're playing one side or the
other,
it's fascinating to see how if you get
to be the north Vietnamese communists
side in this,
how,
how little you have to play with in
terms of real pieces that have any
power,
the other side's got all the good pieces
and yet there's ways to win without them
and that's what I mean.
The guy when I was growing up as guys in
black pajamas beat the US military
incomprehensible,
but an entire generation of military
personnel who were mostly junior
officers in that war would grow up to
influence the way the US military
developed 10,
15,
20,
25 years and now all the way to now in
the footprints of Vietnam are all over
this military.
It's back mostly.
And while it would be sort of outside
the norms of human history to expect us
not to make the same mistakes,
they certainly changed a bunch of things
so that,
well,
this war will never be lost in America's
living rooms.
Again.
As the old saying was,
it's astounding and I'll wrap it up.
So to hear when you,
when you listen to,
or Max Hastings as a war correspondent,
the kind of freedom that they had to
cover that war.
And it was a weird situation because if
you look at press coverage in the second
world war and Korea,
it's highly regulated and censored.
So then the next big war after Korea,
Korea ends in what?
Fifty one,
52.
The next big war starts ramping up 63,
64 in Vietnam with a lot of advisors.
I mean who has 16,500
at one point before the real troops came
in.
Um,
the media all of a sudden doesn't have
those constraints for really the first
time in modern American history
certainly.
And they seem to get less and less
constrained as the war goes on.
And when you see some of these,
there's one famous firefight where the
reporter is what?
I think it's during tet,
where the reporter walks up to US troops
that are,
um,
at a wall I think may be marines that
are a wall and they are fighting
something right on the other side of the
wall.
And they are reloading their weapons and
then standing up and shooting at the
other side of the wall and the reporter
walks right up and starts interviewing.
The guy is,
he's reloading is gun during the
firefight.
Now two things stand out at you right
there.
Number one is that's a ballsy reporter,
right?
That's a war correspondent of the sort
that are just,
they're amazing,
right?
I've always had an admiration for their
willingness to go get the story when
they go get the story like that.
I don't mean Ernie pyle was killed by a
sniper machine gun.
I think actually,
um,
you know,
covering the Second World War.
But the other thing you realize is that,
that is absolutely uncensored work
content coming right back to America's
living rooms.
And if I recall going from memory here,
when the reporter asked the soldier
something like,
you know,
what did he want to reach?
I want to get outta here.
You know what I mean?
It was one of these,
I just want to get out of here.
I just want to get.
I mean,
it was not a pro war Rah Rah Rah thing.
It was something that the folks at home
would go,
oh my goodness,
now here's two sides to this,
um,
side number one is that's reality and
please put me firmly in the camp of,
you know,
if you're going to go to these wars and
you can expect people to support them,
they have to know what it is and they
have to know what it is in living color
just like that.
So I'm on that side,
but let's understand that the other side
is Max Hastings points out in this book
didn't show their people that kind of
press coverage,
right?
So they're rigidly controlling what the
communist people see.
They don't get to see all their death or
their suffering all their atrocities and
the other side's got it in living color.
And our friends who don't like us so
much,
there were some countries that love hate
relationships.
So do they play this stuff up?
Huge.
And you'll notice we didn't have
Americans doing much protesting during
the second world war.
We were bombing Germany and Japan and we
haven't had by Vietnam standards much in
the way of those things since Vietnam.
We had a few big ones,
but you know,
nothing's to stain Vietnam,
the sustained pressure with lots and
lots of people protesting for long time.
I haven't had that sense either.
Could you suggest that maybe it's
because they aren't being exposed to the
same sort of a video and photos and
stories that the American people saw in
the 1960 [inaudible] and 19 seventies?
Well,
if so,
and you can call that one of the,
I guess successful reforms that the army
and Navy and Marine Corp leaders,
the Air Force leader is learned from
that era.
If they believed that the war was lost
in the living room.
Well,
don't do that again and we don't.
But back in supermax Max Hastings Day,
we did.
So I'm pleased to introduce,
if you've never heard him,
well my goodness,
if you never read his books,
if you're a military history fan,
well then you have a whole bunch to pick
up.
I mean,
in Ferno,
go get in front of.
That's a good one.
But this latest one of Vietnam also.
Fantastic.
Uh,
so without further ado,
uh,
I'm honored to talk to Sir Max Hastings
today about his new book,
Vietnam.
Hello,
Max?
Yeah,
listen,
thank you so much.
I'm sure they've got you on the book,
publicity,
a factory assembly line to.
We'll try to make this as painless and
fun as possible.
It'll be completely painless.
Oh,
I'm a big fan actually.
Um,
I will admit though,
I haven't gotten through the latest
book.
I didn't get it in time.
I'm enjoying it immensely though,
and it's a subject near and dear to my
heart as all Americans and in my
generation probably had no way to avoid.
Um,
I was born during the battle of the,
uh,
of the.
I drank valley,
so November 14th,
1965.
I'm 52.
Oh,
well that makes you a generation younger
than me.
Well,
listen,
I want,
and I want to talk about that a little
bit.
It's fascinating to read something from
a 21st century perspective that I
actually grew up in,
in the wake or the wash of a.
and I was wondering,
how different is this book from
something you would have written much
more closer to the time you were in
country now,
for example,
the audience doesn't know this.
Let me make sure that they do.
Um,
this is a book from a British
perspective,
which we don't normally get with Vietnam
war books.
Uh,
it's also,
um,
it's also able to,
as I said,
give us a 21st century,
look back at something that many of the
books I was reading were written in the
19 eighties for example.
And you were actually there.
So,
so give me a perspective a little bit on
how writing this book now was different
than,
than how the 25 or 28 year old,
Sir Max Hastings would have written it.
Stupid officer back in the 19 sixties.
Although I'm British America and its
history has been deeply etched into my
own experience because I lived here in
[inaudible] 67 or 68.
Uh,
and I witnessed up the huge
demonstrations.
Um,
I met a lot of the key players of the
Robert Kennedy's,
the Eugene McCarthy is,
um,
and I went the White House and listened
to Lyndon Johnson haranguing,
a group of US foreign journalists about
up,
about why he was so passionate and
committed to the war.
And this was in January 1968.
And of course we were hugely impressed
to be meeting the president.
That was me,
22 years old sitting in the cabinet
role.
Um,
Johnson.
He behaved in many ways,
quite like his character to in the dea.
Started out by saying saying,
uh,
some of you may like blondes and some
who may like redheads and some of you
may not like women at all,
but I'm here this morning to tell you
what kind I like.
He said,
I'm prepared to sit down with Holcim in
a nice hotel with nice food and sit down
to talk to settle this thing.
And he spoke for 40 minutes and then he
got up and he didn't take questions,
you said.
Right.
Very nice to meet you.
Already went out the room.
But then suddenly,
just as we were gathering together all
notes and we'd been hugely impressed
those how could we not be.
I'm an I was by far the youngest of the
group,
but nonetheless we were all quite a
young group and meeting the president of
the United States.
But suddenly he put his head round the
door again.
I'm a little bit sheepishly and he came
back in and he said,
before you all go,
I'd like to ask your one question
meeting me.
Have any of you changed your minds about
anything you've read or heard about
maybe before you came?
And we were absolutely stunned into
silence by spectacle as the president of
United States.
I'm carrying six months what a load of
kids like us thought.
But that was a reflection of how
vulnerable Johnson felt that.
And then of course,
couple of years later I went to Vietnam
for BBC television on.
I did quite a lot of reporting there
right through until 75 when I came out
of the embassy compound and the final
evacuation.
So this was all etched,
deepen my experience.
But the key thing that has changed
meanwhile is that I very much bought
into the idea that not only was this a
disastrous war,
which indeed it was,
but the because of the United States was
tied up with a bad cause.
Therefore the other sides must be a good
cause.
And I've come to believe having studied
a huge amount of material from north
Vietnam and from the communist side and
so on.
That's really north Vietnam and South
Vietnam I've come to believe were two
rival tyrannies and the idea that g men
was a good guy anymore than march its
own walls or Jay Guevara.
These were absolutely ruthless
revolutionary and they did terrible
stuff.
And whereas everybody has seen the
pictures of the south Vietnamese police
chief of executing the viet cong
prisoner in 1968 on the naked kid
running away after a south Vietnamese
napalm strike.
The communists made very sure that when
our photographs of many of the dreadful
things that their side did,
the terrorism that I'm in,
for instance,
a entirely reliable or story of one
among many village chiefs who was being
buried alive in the Mekong Delta in the
early 19 sixties by the local communists
in front of all these fellow villages to
demonstrate that the price of all on
redacting the revolution was much worse
than death and he pleaded for most of
our bullet and the prominence cadres
just said that they save the bullets for
the,
for the imperialists and in the tet
offensive of 1968 when thousands of
perfectly innocent people whose worse
crime as to support the south.
That means government were executed in
cold blood by the Communist.
Again,
no pictures of we didn't see all this
stuff and I've come to believe that
although I don't believe for a moment
that the war was winnable,
that we weren't.
We did allow ourselves,
those of us who were correspondence that
are all those of us who are reporting
the war.
All we could see,
and most of the stuff we were writing
about was what a terrible mess United
States and the South Vietnamese were
making of it.
And yet we saw in 1975 that when the
communists game par,
um,
the ruthlessness and the incompetence
with which they behaved,
starvation descended on the Vietnamese
people in the 19 eighties and any idea
that the other side,
we're the good guys now seems to be out
of order.
And I've come very strongly to believe.
One is to,
of most events in history that neither
side had a monopoly of a virtue or vice.
So that's one thing.
The second thing I think is hugely
important is that we are overwhelmingly
fact.
We were with the Americans,
um,
and with the US army and the US Marine
Corps and so on.
And we saw this through an American
prison.
And yet this was overwhelming.
They're Vietnamese tragedy.
But while 58,000
Americans died in Vietnam,
something over 2 million,
2 million Vietnamese died,
at least 40 for every American.
Not to mention countless low on
Cambodians as well.
So I spent a huge amount of time
researching a Vietnamese sources and
interviewing Vietnamese and sure there
are a lot of Americans in my story
because the Americans made the big
decisions,
but I've also tried to put the
Vietnamese where they belong,
which is the central of the stage of
this huge tragedy.
Well,
I think you bring up an interesting
quandary that people can understand
because we're confronted with it not
uncommonly,
even in the modern world,
which is with the communist as bad as
they were,
and doing all these things you were
talking about without knowing how the
war was gonna turn out.
Does that legitimize the involvement of
a of one of the two great superpowers of
the time?
In other words,
can you make a moral case that the right
thing was done because this sort of
thing was happening and it was
understood that if the communists took
over South Vietnam,
there'd be a bloodbath and all these
other things,
and yet all of the things that you talk
about in the later part of your book
after the US get involved shows exactly
how nasty it is for the Vietnamese
people.
As you pointed out when we did get
involved for all the right reasons.
How should you know?
Fifty years of thinking about this and
seeing how things play out in the
region.
How do you square the difference
between.
It might be morally right to go in there
and try to save these people from a
terrible fate and yet while doing so,
inflicted even worse fade on them.
I mean,
how do you square?
How does that.
How does that go in your head these
days?
Absolutely.
In my book to people who I got to know a
bit when I was a young reporter covering
his campaign in 68 general gave Jim
Galvin,
whom I also knew who was a world war two
power true here on Jim Gavin and Eugene
McCarthy.
Both said I'm at a pretty early stage.
They said,
whatever the virtue of your cause,
if you fight over a village of five or
six times,
an awful lot of people are going to die
and you find yourself thinking at some
point there's got to be some
proportionality that even if what you
want to achieve in a place and
especially in Vietnam is,
is uh,
something that is worthwhile and decent.
But in the end you find yourself in
danger of destroying the very thing that
you're trying to try to save on.
The has to be proportionality on one
point,
which is at the core of my own book,
is that I think a mistake we've made in
the past and we go on making and
remember the British have been very much
associated with the United States in
Iraq and in Afghanistan and so on.
Is that although there has to be a
military dimension,
if you're going to do these
interventions,
the key thing is always cultural and
social and economic,
and if you can't have some sort of
cultural engagement with these societies
in which you intervene,
then you're completely wasting your time
winning firefights and to me,
and I've said this in the last chapter
of my book,
you go on winning firefights and these
bases and killing bad guys till the cows
come home,
but unless you've got some linkage with
the local people,
and I was always very struck by somebody
who's become a friend.
Hr mcmaster,
who more recently was Donald Trump's
national security advisor that hr
mcmaster,
who's an outstanding American army
officer.
Um,
one day about 2006,
we were having lunch together and he was
telling me about all the great things
that his armored calvary regiment had
done in Iraq.
And then he ended up by saying the
trouble was there was nothing to join up
to.
Now,
what he meant was that there was no sort
of local government,
the local community to be able to fill
in after they'd finished winning the
battles and exactly the same.
Neil Sheehan,
I'm a very famous American correspondent
in Vietnam.
When I was telling him that story a
couple of years ago,
um,
we were discussing and you said it was
the same problem in Vietnam.
There was nothing to join up to.
And I've said in my book that I think
the main reason that the communists
ended up winning in,
in Vietnam was not because they were
particularly better soldiers,
but because they were Vietnamese and
always this problem and it's one sees it
in Iraq and Afghanistan again,
but a lot of the time the locals don't
like foreigners,
whether they are British or American or
whatever.
And um,
I,
I talked to a Vietnamese who's now
become a very successful businessman in
California.
And he was saying to me that when he was
living in Vietnam as a young man,
you said the communists were constantly
reminding us how humiliating it was to
be occupied by the Americans.
They had the monopoly of patriotism.
Um,
what we have to find ways of doing and
these interventions is,
is hard to,
while trying to help these people we
can't take over their country is out.
Of course,
the United States was effectively 64,
65.
Everybody knew that the South Vietnamese
who were supposed to be running the
country couldn't get out of bed in the
morning without asking the Americans
which side to get out.
And the Communists were able to exploit
that.
So although I'm in any idea that was all
the kids thought in the sixties,
that was a sort of saintly figure out
members,
a ruthless revolutionary,
but he achieved a state of status or
stature as the victor in the colonial
war against the French,
which the United States and the,
the,
the what the United States called.
I've still got my old press card from
Vietnam.
Free Weld forces were never able to find
anybody who looked like the Patriots and
the hero and the nationalist.
And how'd she.
Men died on the southern side.
Um,
but I don't know.
The longer I write history books and the
more you come to learn that very often
you can't say it's good Vivo on the
blackfeet why?
These things were always very
complicated and I felt even when I was a
young reporter in Vietnam,
I never thought the United States look
like winning this war,
but even then I never felt the other
side deserved to either.
You bring up some very interesting
points in the book of things that make
you feel like the government is inept
and then you realize,
but we do it over and over again,
so maybe it's built into the,
to the cake.
As we say.
For example,
and to piggyback off the point you just
made about the south Vietnamese
government trying to appear as though
you know they're,
they're,
they're fighting as much of a
nationalist war as the north is.
And yet when we first put marines on
shore in 1965,
as you put pointed out in your book,
we didn't even tell the south Vietnamese
government we were going to do it.
Those are the kinds of things where you
would have loved to have been a fly on
the wall in the,
in the meetings about this.
Did somebody bring that up and say this
is going to look really bad if,
if if we spring this on them or was it
or was the tenor of the times such that
worrying about what a puppet government.
I guess maybe some people would have
called it thought about this was was not
on their top 10 list of concerns.
You're absolutely right.
One of the things that always struck me
as I also said in the book,
all the hot shot meetings in Washington
about Vietnam policy,
no Vietnamese ever attended any of them.
It was always Americans who held the
meetings to decide what was going to be
done in Saigon and you find,
and again I have quoted all the examples
were several times when they discussed
in Washington whether they should change
the Vietnamese government,
but when president two and 1970,
74,
I'm sorry,
73 look like refusing to sign the peace
deal that Henry Kissinger and stitched
up.
I'm in Paris with the North Vietnamese.
There was a serious discussion in
Washington about whether to just get rid
of president to input in another
Vietnamese president.
Well,
it's not too surprising that the
Vietnamese feel humiliated.
I mean,
all human relations about who makes her
feel good and Americans did not make,
um,
Vietnamese feel good.
And I say this is not unique to
Americans.
I mean,
I've seen it myself in Afghanistan with
British troops and Salma,
um,
unless you can,
although I don't particularly like that
phrase,
hearts and minds,
unless you can make and help other
nations to have self respect and to feel
good about themselves.
Well,
it's always going to be already a tough
row to hoe.
But one thing I do want to say,
which I've also tried to get into my
book.
I do think that Americans today are
sometimes almost floods and atria and
their approach to the war.
Oh God.
We were so wicked.
Well,
although there's no doubt the war was a
disaster.
A lot of Americans,
some of whom I've interviewed for the
book went to Vietnam where the highest
ideals of service,
both some soldiers and some civilians.
I've been hugely moved by.
Some of the Americans I interviewed for
the book.
They really cared some of the civilians,
especially the language.
They completely threw themselves into
the whole thing and they weren't sort of
wicked imperialists who wanted to do
terrible things that they were people
who really wanted to do good deeds and a
wicked world and I think that a lot of
the histories of the war don't pay
sufficient tribute to some of these
people.
I mean,
one guy who made an enormous impression
on me,
I was done on the west coast.
I'm interviewing Vietnamese and I heard
about a guy called Dave Ramsey who might
heard about it,
but I never had no idea.
He was still alive and I was told he was
still alive and living in boulder city.
Nevada and I looked at the map and it
was more than 300 miles driving my car
over from the west coast,
the boulder city.
But I just thought I may be able to go
and see this guy and I got the car and
it's a hell of a long drive across the
desert and I got to build a city on.
There was Doug Ramsey and I spent four
hours with him and it was an amazing
business because Doug Ramsey was a
foreign service officer,
a really outstanding American who I'm in
1962.
He made up his mind,
he wants you to go and serve in Vietnam
and was involved in pacification
programs or systems for time to John
Paul Vann the,
um,
the very famous American advisor out
there.
And Doug Ramsey passionately cared about
the Vietnamese.
He learned.
He learned Vietnamese.
Um,
he,
he wrote a lot of stuff for some of his
letters home,
which you gave me were huge,
hugely moving.
But then beginning of 66,
he was driving a truck with a load of
rise up to some village and he got out
Bush by the Viet Cong and captured on.
He spent the next seven years,
not in the Hilton,
but in a bamboo cage in the jungle.
Seven years you have malaria,
123 times he had every kind of other
tropical disease are you survive?
God only knows.
And yet he came out of this experience,
um,
is health absolutely destroyed.
I mean,
when I saw him,
he could hardly move his body at all,
but his mind was still right on and he
taught so moving live because even
though he'd suffered so terribly at the
hands of the Communist,
um,
that he was completely even handed in
seeing the good stuff and the bad stuff
about.
And he knew the Viet Cong having been a
prisoner for seven years,
better than almost anybody else.
I mean,
he taught me some very funny stories.
one of them that always stuck in my
mind.
Um,
you said one day when he was being
interviewed by his interrogators and he
told them that he thought that the
Americans were in Vietnam 10 percent to
help the Vietnamese people are 90
percent to hold back the Chinese and
artsy tongue.
And he said the communist interrogator
applied.
In that case,
why do you not go and fight him in
China?
We do not like the Chinese either.
Um,
another story he told,
which was sort of somehow the subject of
Tom Hayden came into conversation.
Jane Fonda's,
a husband who are of course fall in love
with Oge men and Koa and spent half his
time in,
up in north Vietnam telling you the
North Vietnamese are wonderful.
They were.
And when Tom Haynes name was mentioned,
uh,
Doug Ramsey,
he asked his interrogators these.
He said,
well,
what do you think of Tom Hayden?
And they said,
we think his ideology is excellent,
was a man,
we despise him.
How could you respect to manual?
But Tracy's own country like that,
alluded to it with the,
as you said,
these soldiers who went in here for such
idealistic reasons.
I mean,
you quoted a,
uh,
a man named Harry Williams who had
mentioned,
you know,
we were doing good.
We were making a real contribution.
We were making things better.
Um,
it reminds me because I was sort of the
younger brother of that baby boom
generation that gets so much heat these
days and so much flack and yet at the
same time,
it's hard to not notice that that
generation is a bunch of younger people
were extremely idealistic and motivated
by their idealism.
Some went into the peace corps.
A lot of this,
as you point out,
was in response to John f Kennedy's
famous sacrifice speech,
but some of these people did a similar
sort of approach and trying to make the
world a better place by doing what you
mentioned parachuting into Laos and
trying to,
to,
uh,
cut off the Ho Chi Minh trail so that
the people in the south good.
I mean,
it's,
it's fascinating to know the word
watershed moment.
The phrase watershed moment is overused,
but it's hard to not notice the
difference between 19,
63 United States of America in 1973
United States of America and not
attribute a large part of the
disillusionment and the change in
attitudes to that war.
Does that seem right?
To go back to your question about why do
I think a lot of people make the mistake
when they look back at historical
events,
but they look at them through a 2018
prism.
For me,
the only way to ride history is to close
your eyes and try and remember how
things look to people.
Then on the first thing to be said about
the 19 fifties and sixties,
the really was a communist threat,
but worldwide.
Um,
the,
um,
the Soviet Union and the Chinese did
represent deeply unpleasant totalitarian
forces of history.
I'm quite confident will show that the
United States with absolutely right to
lead the western nations in resisting.
We were the good guys in the Cold War
and I have no doubt about that.
So sometimes when people say,
oh,
well,
they never really was a common thread.
The most certainly was a communist
threat.
They were very nice to people.
However they did not.
They did get a terrible tangle and into
China because there weren't enough
people in Washington who really
understood the nuances and understood
the nuances,
the nationalism.
And one of the things I discovered in
the course of researching the book,
which I had no idea about the Chinese
and the Russians fall from being I'm
enthusiastic about the Vietnam war,
hated the whole business because they
were having to throw shed loads of money
and resources of weapons.
I mean,
the Russians were giving the north
Vietnamese half a billion dollars a
year,
which they could afford,
but they felt because they,
the Chinese,
the Russians for competing for
leadership,
all the socialist world,
they had to go on backing this war.
But our intelligence,
Western intelligence was so bad that
nobody had the inkling of the so that
right through to Nixon and Kissinger,
they still believed in the early
seventies that all our actions had to do
is pick up the phone to talk to,
um,
I know I,
and,
um,
the north Vietnamese and make a deal.
And it wasn't like that at all.
That I've quoted Brezhnev when he was
leader Russia saying to the Russian
ambassador in Washington,
I have no desire to drown in the swamps
of Vietnam.
And he felt himself almost as much a
prisoner of all this stuff as,
um,
as the American step.
He hated it,
but they were all stuck in this
situation.
The other thing too,
which I saw the tail end of when I was
living here in the sixties,
was that America after the Second World
War and had achieved such awesome
success.
I was so powerful and so rich,
but it seemed to that generation of
Americans that nothing was impossible
and no presidents on this very much
applied to Lbj,
but also to Kennedy.
None of them wanted to be the ones to
tell the American people that before
might of the United States couldn't see
often load a raggedy ass communist
guerrillas.
And there's a very good phrase of
Kennedy's that made a great impression
on me.
I mean,
I often hear people say,
and I don't believe it,
but if Kennedy had lived either God
America out of Vietnam,
Kennedy told Jay k galbraith is key.
An economic advisor,
um,
a few weeks before he was killed,
he said they're only just so many
concessions I can make to the communists
in any one year.
And asked the American people to reelect
me and American expectations,
the belief among the American people,
and certainly in American government
that if America wanted something,
it must be doable.
This was very strong,
but of course,
as you so rightly said,
Vietnam went forward to destroying this.
And one of my heroes in this book,
or boomer,
a marine officer who might spend a lot
of time with and admired enormously
won't boomer,
um,
said,
said to me,
he said,
nothing you said in my lifetime,
uh,
has changed America more than Vietnam.
He said it created a mistrust and
suspicion of government and of the
people in charge that we've never been
able to undo.
And I think he's right about that,
don't you?
I think that's maybe one of the most
persistent things in the war,
that credibility gap.
And it's hard to describe to Americans
now how,
as you pointed out in your book,
Americans would believe their president
most of the time,
regardless of which he even was.
And it's never been the same.
The other thing,
as you point out,
and as everyone knows,
but it's not talked about enough that it
changed,
is it sort of because it was the second
major time,
it sort of codified the change,
the unspoken change in the US
constitutional system where we no longer
declared war.
You could describe Korea as an outlier
if it was once upon a time,
but Vietnam becomes the time where we
sort of codified this and I was
interested very much in,
in how you pointed out that the,
the legal advisor to the president was
explaining,
you know,
how you could get around having to
declare a war.
Um,
I was also very interested in the,
in the Munich question.
It was fascinating to me how this
specter of appeasement and Munich was
sort of hanging over the decision making
process and how it played into the
domestic politics and how it could
almost be used if you,
if you compare it to a schoolyard brawl,
one side,
calling the other a coward and demanding
they move.
Even if moving wasn't the right
political choice.
Um,
we still have the whole Munich
appeasement cudgel at work in today's
modern American politics.
Can you talk about that and the
credibility gap a little bit?
What was a big scene to be weak?
But it's,
it's very difficult.
I mean,
I think one of the things I find as I
get older,
and I hope that one is a different
person from what I was when I was a
young reporter.
I meant to tell you a terrible story.
Um,
I grew up in a household in which all
the men in the house,
including my father banged on and on
about what a wonderful time they'd had
in world war two.
And I grew up believing with
extraordinary neighbor to the wars were
great adventures and um,
I started out that way and I did the
parachutes with our own,
our own people and all the restaurant
when I was 17.
And I really thought that this was all
terrific romantic stuff.
And really my whole life as a writer has
been a sort of journey of discovering
the walls are like that.
That was a very serious stuff.
And there's a great phrase which I
sometimes quote to student audiences,
but,
um,
I suppose the lesson it's taken me 50
years to learn was quoted by Norwegian
Resistance Shero called knute constant
knute Hanson,
um,
after doing wonderful things with world
war two.
You raised memoirs in 1948.
And in his book he wrote,
although was bringing adventures that
stirred the heart,
the true nature of war is composed of
innumerable personal tragedies and
sacrifices.
Wholly evil are not redeemed by glory.
Now he,
I think he's absolutely right about
that.
And I find in my books these days,
I write far more about victims that I do
about soldiers.
But I think one of the things,
there are many things that you do learn
to have a,
a sort of respect for the dilemmas
facing governments.
That it's very difficult for all
governments at all times to decide when
to be strong and when to give way.
And it's,
it used to seem so easy to just send the
hundred and first airborne all the US
Marine Corps to sort out your problems.
What are,
we know it's not that simple,
but in the end if you can't sort out the
cultural issues in these countries,
the hundred and first airborne,
all the US Marine Corps can't solve them
for you any more than our own army camp
and up.
But I think if one looks at history one
see moments,
I mean we can all.
We all see now that Kennedy was both
courageous and bold at the time of the,
of the Cuban missile crisis,
which could have gone horribly wrong,
but sometimes when presidents.
I'm in Lyndon Johnson,
terribly wanted to be seen to be
courageous and to be doing the right
thing as the leader of the United States
by sending in troops to Vietnam.
But of course you've got it wrong,
but I,
I.
What I'd like to feel is that through my
own narratives,
one is all the time trying to realize
that governments are trying to do very
difficult things.
I don't just mean in the United States
government in the context of Vietnam,
but most governments most of the time
and the same way for military
commanders.
I mean,
I've seen enough wars myself as a
reporter,
I'm one scene,
the not terrible things on the
battlefield,
but it is very difficult to,
uh,
to fight wars.
It is not as my father and his friends
used to say,
oh,
it's all a great wrong.
Um,
it's very tough out there on the
battlefield and,
and I've,
I find that at the age of 72,
I have a huge sympathy with the people
who make the decisions that I didn't
have a when I was a stupid young kid.
Everyone involved in the decision making
process of moving from a,
a,
a more passive advisor role to putting
troops on the ground.
I'm going to quote you here.
You wrote quote,
none doubted that the war would be long
and the cost immense quite unlike,
for instance,
to 2002 decision to invade Iraq in 1965,
every hazard was anticipated.
I not only found that an interesting
line,
I found that to be a new piece of
information for me.
And I've read quite a few books on
Vietnam,
but it's been a while.
And,
and that was something that I think
changed my paradigm a little.
Um,
can you explain that because it is
interesting to think you would commit
eventually half a million troops and,
and yet understand how it might not even
be winnable and understand how tough
it's going to be a and not understand,
as you said,
the difference between Asian communism
and Soviet communism.
Um,
can you talk about that a little bit?
Not in the Johnson White House State
Department is Memoranda on the things
you said in conversations with the White
House,
with the president.
He wound all along as in thethe does
some of the generals,
uh,
that they didn't think that a jungle war
in,
in the swamps of the mountains of
Vietnam was going to be the kind that
suited the US army.
Um,
I'm,
one of the problems I'm afraid we're
already prone to is that we can be
terribly impressed by how my trn forces
look that if you see I'm a US carrier
group at sea and if you see a always
terrific on jets taking off from the
flight decks and if you see your,
your marines storming through the surf,
and so they all look so impressive that
you can't believe anything can stand up
to them,
but the word people,
smart people in positions of influence
in the sixties who did clearly identify
the fact that this was going to be very
tough and that kind of war in the jungle
against guerrillas might well not suit
Americans.
I'm part of it.
One of the things a lot of people George
Ball said very smartly,
he said,
Mr.
President,
if I thought this could be done in a
year.
He said,
I went back through all the way,
but he said,
I think it's going to take much longer,
and I do not believe that the American
people will have the patients for a long
walk.
And one of the key things is
democracies.
Light was to be over quick and I always
say it's sort of half amuses me that
Mike,
the last job I did a as a war
correspondent,
I reported the British Falklands War and
no to the British love the Falklands War
because we had an incredibly incompetent
enemy in the eyes and tight army and it
was all over very quickly and we won.
Um,
and that's the sort of war everybody
wants,
but unfortunately it's not the kind of
war you will get.
Um,
but now I am impressed,
but the number of smart people,
some of them in uniform who clearly saw
but,
but one of the problems facing chiefs of
staff and that was true now and that if
your a political leader,
your president or prime minister says,
can you do this?
Well,
senior generals and admirals and an Ama,
they know they've got to justify this
stupendous costs of the armed forces.
And you've got to be quite a brave man
to tell your head of state or your,
your chief executive,
um,
that your forces can't do this or that.
I'm in.
I remember being amused.
I'm a 2002 just before the invasion of
Iraq and I was friendly with our then
head of the army and I met him one day
when you just come back from.
I'm from Washington,
we've been at a planning meeting for the
invasion of Iraq.
And I said,
well,
what do you make of?
And he said,
well,
he said getting into Baghdad it's going
to be dead easy.
But he said that in the slightest idea
what they're going to do when they get
that.
Um,
but at that time,
um,
that to um,
the,
um,
the people making the decisions in
Washington didn't seem too much of a
problem.
But I'm the worst smart people back in
64,
65 who did see that this was going to be
a very tough road to hoe.
Um,
but so,
but the people to be,
I don't know,
again,
was always mixed up between horror at
some of the stupid people who did bad
things both in uniform and out of it.
And also admiration.
Again,
I'm in some of the soldiers and some of
the Marines on some of the abstinence
song within the framework of a disaster.
They did very fine things and I find
myself still admiring hugely what they
achieved.
An alright.
You may say you're going to be a,
you say,
well,
it was all for nothing.
But mind you,
I have to say one story that sticks very
much in my mind.
One of the most impressive people I
interviewed was a former corpsman,
a medic with the infantry guy called
David Rogers.
I'm a David Rogers described being very
movingly.
His experiences with his platoon of who
we said about a third were killed or
wounded up north of Saigon in about 69
70.
And um,
he said,
I mean,
he was very emotionally affected by the
war and remain so.
But he said,
I'm in 1993.
He was one of those who have the
Vietnamese invited back as a guest to
come and visit the country again.
And he went as a reporter and he said
they took him to the area where he'd
fought with his unit and he said all the
Viet Cong embraced him,
um,
because they rolled under strict orders
to be incredibly nice to Americans
because they wanted Congress to pass a
trade deal on.
David Rogers said to me what I had to
Redo a couple of years ago.
He said I couldn't help thinking they've
all these guys while he was a
Mcdonald's,
couldn't we have sorted this out a long
time ago?
Johnson was offering if they would just
stop infiltrating the south.
Let me ask you something that's a little
close to home.
Maybe I want to talk about the media
coverage because this proverbially the
war that was lost in America's living
rooms and all that kind of stuff.
I've found some of the things you said
very interesting.
I mean,
for example,
you brought up a point that had never
occurred to me.
I'm quoting here,
I think,
or close to it that,
um,
that Vietnam war era reporters enjoyed a
notable advantage over most of their
successors in the 21st century because
they themselves at often served in
uniform and we're familiar with weapons
and military ways.
Sure.
Uh,
and,
and the other thing that I found
interesting was when you talked about
the line that some Americans went to
their graves believing that reporters
betrayed their country while winning
applaudance from the media counterparts
around the world.
Um,
can you talk a little bit about media
coverage?
I mean,
for example,
I don't think we've seen because before
that war,
the war coverage was very censored,
world war type stuff.
And yet somehow after that war,
they've toned down.
I mean,
now we have embedded reporters who are
essentially working with the
governments.
I don't think we've ever seen the kind
of freedom to show news the way they did
in that war.
And do you think that was a good thing
or a bad thing?
And do you think the reporters at the
time did a good enough job pointing out
what you mentioned,
the other side's transgressions and
atrocities and everything so that things
would be equal a little bit
in the introduction to my book,
think many of the reporters who served
in Vietnam did not standing job of
reporting entirely accurately what they
themselves saw and knew where they
failed was because it was so much going
on on the other side that they had no
access to,
but I'm an incredibly bad stuff,
but the other side was doing never got
any sort of show and I quite understand
in a very small way I was party to it
myself because you know,
when I was reporting for BBC and
newspapers in the early seventies and
all the time you were seeing shocking
stuff been going on all around you and
you were witness to the corruption on
the incompetence of the South Vietnamese
government.
But we just didn't pay enough attention
to this stuff we couldn't see and the
United States.
Whereas it was absolutely true that
there was a huge credibility gap because
a lot of the stuff that was a,
we were told that briefings and solve
with absolute garbage,
um,
but the numbers,
all this stuff up,
body counts and so on.
The frightful lies were told in fact,
boomer,
the General Marine Corps general.
And he said to me that one of the
lessons he brought home from three tours
in Vietnam was telling the truth.
But the curious thing that the sort of
contradiction on the one hand a lot of
senior Americans did not tell the truth
to the world about what was happening.
But on the other hand,
America dippers have a commitment that
was very honorable to let us see for
ourselves.
So that in a way that's never been
repeated in any war sense.
That if any of us,
I'm sort of didn't believe what we were
being told about.
Some bell going off in the middle of
nowhere.
We could get access on me as a British
journalist,
as much as anybody on fixed wing
aircraft and helicopters to go there and
look for ourselves and the Communists
would never let anybody but Jane Fonda
go up and see what the hell was going on
in that neck of the woods.
Um,
and I do not believe that the business,
the media lost the war,
but I certainly do believe that,
uh,
the way the war was covered up made it
more difficult for the United States.
But,
um,
I mean a point,
my father was a war correspondent in
world war two and I once said to him
that having been reading some of his
wartime dispatchers,
they seem to be pretty gung Ho.
And he said what we were doing as part
of the war effort.
Now,
of course,
nearly all the senior officers who were
in Vietnam,
American senior officers,
they'd been in world war two and they
were accustomed to dealing with the
media that would play the game.
I'm in what was seen to be in the
national interest.
They wouldn't break ranks.
And now suddenly in Vietnam they find
that you've got a whole lot of reporters
refused to accept that I'm telling the
story the way that Mac v is,
they've always known of one of the toll
was,
was not going to happen,
and they found it very difficult to
adjust to this.
Um,
and I think what is also fair,
but some John,
this I think it would be dishonest
about.
I mean I was taking apart the television
discussion a year or so ago with a group
of former war correspondents,
including some Americans.
And I said they were talking about their
commitment to tell the truth and tell
the world what was going on.
And I said,
shouldn't we also met that when you're,
when you're as young as we all were and
so on.
It was a great adventure.
And we had the time of our lives in many
ways.
We were all responsible kids.
Well,
none of the others would admit that at
all.
In fact,
they got very angry with me for saying
that.
But I'm afraid the were in Vietnam.
A lot of the journalists were frankly,
what I would call war tourists.
Um,
there was some brilliant,
serious minded super people like Neil
CNN,
David Halberstam,
and so,
so there were some very fine
correspondence,
but I'm in,
it was a great life.
There were unlimited girls drugs,
delicious food,
beautiful country and all rest of it.
Um,
and although some of the media,
how they find this in Vietnam,
um,
I would also say that some of the media
had the unfinished style,
like the television crew that provided a
knife for a soldier to cut the ears off,
some dead Viet Cong on camera and that
sort of stuff.
So,
um,
the media,
his record in Vietnam was pretty mixed.
Um,
there was some stuff we're proud open
some stuff,
frankly the same dog
in terms of protests and everything else
because it's interesting as a kid
growing up in the post Vietnam era,
I just thought that was the new reality
that would be expected in future
conflicts.
And yet now looking 50 years back on
things,
if you really,
if you start in the second world war,
there's very little of that large spike
in anti war activity.
I mean,
not only were there no protesters
protesting the bombing of Germany and
Japan,
but they're really by 1960 standards
weren't that much after the Vietnam War
for any of the conflicts.
What do you think accounts for that
being such an outlier situation?
I've suggested in my book,
I remember I was living here in the late
sixties,
so I saw it,
the demonstrations and the whole thing,
but all sorts of stuff got tangled up
together.
It was the worldwide youth movement
against the established order on the
revolt against the old sexual morality
and the enthusiasm of a part of the and
all this stuff got rolled up with
Vietnam.
Um,
and you've got to remember,
kids in those days were putting posters
on their college walls or we Tang who,
anybody who knows anything knows was one
of the great mass murderers of the 20th
century up there with,
with Hitler.
So,
um,
the walls,
incredible naivety among the kids.
The kids were right about one thing,
the war was a disaster,
but of course one of the things that
drove the protest movement was the fact
that a lot of them were terrified of
being drafted,
um,
that they were afraid they were going to
have to waste two years of their lives
in uniform and maybe lose their lives
all together.
So I'm mixed up with the principle
objections to the war and mixed up with
the whole youth revolt was they felt
they had skin in the game about,
about the danger to themselves.
And they were,
I mean,
it was an extraordinary time to be here.
some of the stuff that I saw myself,
um,
was you actually felt America was
falling apart in 1968.
And in fact,
the fact that it didn't fall apart.
I've never gone to a bank of America
ever since.
One's always,
I always believed passionate this day.
And America is capacity of reinvention
because I saw what a mess it could get
itself into it in [inaudible] 68 and
come out the other side,
but no subsequent war.
The other thing we must remember,
the whole thing was much smaller and we
probably talked too much in this
conversation about all the battlefields
stuff and um,
if you look at casualties,
I mean I've written about one battle in
one chapter of my book called Dido that
absolute nobody's ever heard of and this
was a three day battle in May,
19,
68 in which are marine battalion.
It was more or less wiped out,
up near the demilitarized in three days
of bottling,
which they lost 81 killed and I forget
about 250 wounded and they ended up with
one on wounded officer and I'm about 150
men still fit for combat and nothing
remotely like that happened in Iraq or
in Afghanistan.
I mean,
the scale.
This was a,
a really murderous bloody business in,
in some of the stuff people did and some
of the stuff people experienced.
Um,
I mean it was,
it was,
it was as bad as well too,
or career at times.
I mean,
um,
but I don't think.
I don't buy the line that Vietnam is the
worst world that ever was.
I'm in all wars are pretty ghastly,
but it was a hell of a lot worse,
um,
in the scale of the bloodbath than
anything remotely in Afghanistan or Iraq
and these are volunteer.
They've been fought by volunteer
soldiers
magazine killed that week and sometimes
the casualty levels could get high
enough,
a hundreds a week.
Then I would say.
And I was trying to figure out how we
would react today in the United States
to casualty.
Well,
and that brings me back to something you
had talked about,
the war being a disaster and then we had
talked about the protesters in the media
and everything.
It does make me wonder though,
what is the responsibility if your
government seems on a course to continue
doubling down on something that everyone
knows is a disaster in a democratic or
republican system.
What is the role of the population in
terms of checking a government that,
as you said,
didn't know what they were getting into
or didn't know what they were getting
into but found no way out of where they
were going.
I mean,
could one make the case that it was
better to have that kind of pressure on
the part of the electorate versus what
might have happened if that pressure had
not been there?
What I was living in the United States,
I could see a lot of Americans,
especially in middle America,
Middle America,
very well in that era in Minnesota and
Wisconsin.
And you saw very patriotic Americans
wrestling with the dilemma of,
well,
loyalty.
Les,
did you just blindly go on supporting
your president or,
or did you not?
They weren't to kind of go out and
protest in the streets,
but it's a very difficult issue and I
think it is right.
Just speak up.
But,
um,
it's never easy to decide where the
patriotic root lies.
And I remember one of the most moving
things that,
that happened to me,
um,
when I was there in 71 and I've been up
reporting for BBC of Battle of
playschool Farber's six up in the,
in the,
you know,
the border hell of a murderous business.
And we hitched a ride back.
Saigon on a c 1:30.
That was only one other camera crew,
wally,
he was so in the cargo hold of this huge
aircraft on down at the end of the plane
or the opposite.
Then from us was the body bag,
an American sergeants and advisor,
um,
who have been killed in the battle and
there's his body bag with all his stuff
around him,
his guitar and the sound system on all
these kids.
And so on.
Um,
we had an hour and a half or two hours
on the plane down to Saigon looking.
I was sort of looking at this,
that poor bastard,
he,
he's an,
he's a body bag and so on.
And I thought we're now in a situation
where nobody wants to be the last
American to die in a war that's
obviously lost.
And I think one of the things that one
does bitterly reproached Nixon and
Kissinger for from the moment they
assumed office in [inaudible] 69.
They knew there was no hope of winning
the war,
but they were desperate for purely
political reasons,
to conceal from the American people
about the war was lost and 22,000
Americans died under the Nixon
presidency and I'm Vietnamese and it was
in many ways the worst period because
you've got the whole black power thing.
You've got the army in Vietnam falling
apart,
a huge drug problems and so on and so
forth and all this.
They knew all the way down the street.
There was no way they were going to win
this,
but they were just desperate to avoid
anybody finding out about this.
And to me,
one of the grizzlies bits,
the White House tapes were relatively
recently released in 2015 is a kissinger
coming back from the secret Paris peace
talks in October 72 and he rushes into
the of the Oval Office and he says,
next.
He says,
Mr.
President,
we have got a better deal than you have
ever dreamed on.
And remember,
this is a month before Nixon faces
George Mcgovern in the presidential
election and Kissinger doesn't say this
is going to bring peace.
There's going to save countless lives.
He said this will absolutely,
totally screwed mcgough and the cynicism
of these guys at this stage,
um,
and it was all about politics and,
and that's a pretty.
It's,
it's,
it's hard.
It sticks in your crawl,
you know.
But actually one thing I would say,
which I think is important as a sort of
closing note on this,
to me,
the supreme irony of the war,
if you go to Vietnam today,
um,
if you'd said to an American and about
66,
how would you like Saigon to look in
2018?
We'll actually,
it'd be pretty much the way it looks
now.
And although it's still a very
unpleasant totalitarian state vet now
they do now have license to make money.
They want to be Americans.
They're incredibly nice to Americans
because they realize that the American
system is,
um,
worth countless more valuable and can't
this a more valid than their own Richard
government.
Um,
but they're all completely hooked on
American culture and on making money.
And I've suggested in the last chapter
of my book,
the United States failed in Vietnam,
will be 52 years and spooky gunships and
defoliation the united trial.
I'm with Johnny Depp on Youtube,
but what we've learned is that is the
economic forces can be at least as
important if not more so than than
soldiers.
And deciding how history plays out.
Rock and roll and Playboy magazine.
It'll become American.
You said it the way
Max.
We've hardly touched upon all the good
things in this book though,
and I would like to encourage anyone who
would love to get an updated really
interesting view of Vietnam from
somebody who wasn't just there but has
had a chance to think and talk and do
research about it ever since sir.
Max Hastings and the book is Vietnam a
certain Max.
Thank you so much for coming on.
The program.
Had a great time.
Hey,
come on.
The next book.
Okay.
Take care.
Wrath of the cons,
punic nightmares,
Apache tears,
and of course ghosts of the Austin
Front.
Just a few of the classic hardcore
history titles available from Dan Carlin
Dot com.
Every true fan is hurt.
These favorites.
Hey,
they make great gifts too.
If you think the show you just heard is
worth a dollar,
Dan and Ben would love to have it,
but it's all we ask.
Go to Dan Carlin.com
for information on how to donate to the
show.